alta chaverra desde temprana edad se vio
obligada a abandonar sus sueños es
originaria del departamento del choco en
colombia una de las zonas más
empobrecidas y golpeadas por el
conflicto armado de ese país con
nostalgia recuerda su infancia quien
realmente me mezcla avisaron de niña y
fue mi propia familia antes de ser
llevada a otra ciudad para trabajar como
empleada doméstica en una casa ajena
reynalda cuidaba a sus cuatro hermanos
desde los nueve años ser mujer negra
adolescente y llegará al mundo del
servicio doméstico es muy duro a mí me
negaban el salario por ser menor de edad
pero colombia no es el único país
latinoamericano donde las difíciles
condiciones socioeconómicas empujan a
las niñas a trabajar en contra de su
voluntad oa estar involucradas en las
tareas domésticas de sus propias casas
según la cepal los países con los
porcentajes más altos de trabajo
infantil son bolivia paraguay y perú
para uno mujer es la causa de que las
niñas sean las que más trabajen en los
hogares es el machismo estructural por
lo que la solución al trabajo infantil
debe tener un enfoque de género y
sociedad que se replica y reproduce esos
patrones sociales de género
combatir esta problemática social se
vuelve aún más complejo al no haber
consenso en las cifras lo que convierte
el trabajo infantil en un ciclo de
violencia invisible en latinoamérica